hi welcome back to three scary games
been a while
you know doing so many of these you
start to become numb
to the things that you think you see out
of the corner of your eye
you swear that there's things lurking
right behind you
looking at you watching you and
you forget that you're supposed to not
look at them
you're supposed to not acknowledge them
the monsters in the corners of your eyes
they're very real
all right this is psycho no sutoka
which is a i'm guessing yandere
type horror game and i'm guessing i'm
not the yandere this time
you're trapped here you need to escape
this school the exit door is currently
locked find out how to unlock the exit
doors by looking around for clues please
be aware of the crazy girl in the
vicinity you can use
woz to move interact with e such as
opening or taking a key please remember
that you can only hold one key at a time
shift run
please be careful she can hear you while
you're running well i have nothing to
fear
you need to escape from the exit door i
did not want to do it sorry
escape from the exit door uh what do you
mean whoa lag
okay e e
ah finally
oh oh i didn't know that that would do
anything for you please tell me that you
didn't know
i can crouch okay
this should probably be fine hey no i'm
not in that room what are you talking
about
what do you mean
[Music]
no no no no no no no hey hi
oh hey i'm handsome how are you oh
[Music]
okay cool thank you okay don't push the
beat boops find the code to unlock the
safe and
i don't want to do it what do you mean
there's no point in hiding
don't run towards the locker she can
hear you oh
i see i see
are you coming for me you better not be
i'm too strong
hey say i'm afraid of you the answer is
yes
extremely actually yeah i don't know the
layout of this school yet
oh no i'm not in this room what room do
you mean
i don't know where you are and uh
frankly
huh are you in here you right in front
of me
oh that doesn't sound good
i doubt that this actually leads to exit
even though it says exit
definitely not actually exit oh
[Music]
that's not how doors work okay this is a
bad idea
well this game is a bit of a problem
so ah no
i'm not no i'm not that's locked okay so
that's locked
well that's good to know this is not
locked where was
oh key that looks like a key
what key c3 door key isn't that the one
that i was just at
quadruple x incredible
that's a lot of kisses isn't that the
door that was just like right here no
that's c1
and this is c2 then where would
excellent excellent i love this
oh it's the code six
ah interesting so i got one piece of the
code
six that's good to know probably in each
of the wings
some code is there so six
there's a lot of point in hiding there's
a lot of point
some big point in hiding definitely okay
nothing helpful there so the codes are
distributed around the other rooms
that's locked
no no i think you're over there
legitimately you're over there all right
nothing in here right computer room
that sounds fun
[Music]
someone looking at porn in here okay
exit
i don't believe it oh yep
shouldn't have believed it just gonna
keep on moving because i'm pretty sure
i'm not gonna make it
but if i keep on moving my chances go up
exponentially
[Music]
that sounds close oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god give me give me in
close close close
where are the teachers did you kill the
teachers
[Music]
no
that's how this works watch this noise
i'm then not gonna go through that door
because it was a
fake out and i'm gonna go through here
you're never gonna suspect a thing
and oh was that in here idiot
[Music]
okay there's no more code in here oh yes
there is
the second code number thing is
nine six nine that's nice
i don't think she's going to come back
in here but i'm just being safe didn't
even read what the key was c1
okay good okay c1 i like that i like
that i like that a lot
not coming back here six nine
okay oh ah that's not
fair at all
i'm gonna close this on you oh you're
not very fast
okay that's good i can run away from you
wow
did you do that how did how did you do
that
how did you do that how
how did you do that
[Music]
six nine four this is going great
this is going wonderfully oh this is
going terribly
six nine four six nine four
close the door are you still there no
you vanished oh there you are you're
over there
okay yes it's fine it's fine so you can
run away
you can run it's really only if you get
cornered that's bad
six nine four so i gotta find the d key
that's probably gonna be the last one
six
nine four six nine four
library oh
it's fine six nine four six nine
four okay there's another key here
somewhere somewhere in here
no no no no listen hey don't just don't
even bother you don't even want a piece
of this
that was close sounded close six nine
four six nine four six nine
four i probably shouldn't be running so
much but
you know how it'd be yes
yes yes
six nine four seven six nine four seven
six nine four seven okay got it six nine
four seven
easy easy peasy lemon squeezy six nine
six nine four seven so i just gotta get
back upstairs to that room punch in the
coat on the locker six nine four seven
and we golden
no i'd rather not i don't want to
six nine four seven enter
okay
close close close it who
no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
how did you get there okay i'm just
waiting for her to get some distance up
[Music]
rain check i just need to get down to
the exit
be really dumb if i died now that should
be enough
[Music]
okay
wait a minute no that's not fair how'd
you make me drop that how'd you do that
how did you do that where are you going
where you come from
where what she just what was that all
about
why stop that don't be like that
do it literally don't be like that be
the opposite of whatever that was
i don't know i think she wow do you stop
doing that give god
i did it i did it you've got no nose i
did it
no no there's no nose that's good i like
that
once you start to get the mechanics it's
a little easy to get away from her
but it was very scary at first very very
scary so g very good i like that
i like that check
everything on the desk before playing
the vhs tape press
tab for options and controls and press
escape to exit the game
why would i want to exit can i zoom no
yes
i can this
right here is cage face the man
with the face of a cage
why i don't think anybody could possibly
know i don't think it's something that
can be known
it just is sorry couldn't wait i'll lay
some glow sticks find me
ps record everything why is this letter
blood stained
why are you laying glow sticks what
couldn't you wait for that could
possibly throw you into the jaws of cage
face and ps record everything why don't
you record everything why don't you stop
recording your blood on your notes and
start recording some
vhs tapes maybe you did i don't know all
right
uh in violent type of death violent
found dead
okay multiple stab wounds to the body
the possible weapon used for such wounds
could be a pickaxe
stab wound through the heart homicide
okay well that's not good
okay oh i'm not gonna read all this
oh this is so much to read the lore
let's see and summarize it for me and
then somehow get it to me
uh in reverse time so that i know it now
and i don't have to know it later
oh it's an infusion of knowledge in my
face all the effects are so glowy
okay anyway now i know i know it's all
about it's a man with a
face of cage two bodies found in subway
tunnel police earlier this friday
identified the corpses of two men known
as p
peverist and havery who were found in a
tuttle within the chicago subway the
cause of death does not seem to be an
accident of any kind but rather a
murder deliberate jabs with a sharp
object leaving deep wounds have been
detected on several body parts
okay cool mine shut down dude deadly gas
well which is it
is it the pickaxe murderer or is it the
deadly gas
oh saying recollections of a man with a
deformed face stalking him keep haunting
his mind
sure okay well i don't know what it is
and i don't know which one's which but i
investigated everything i'm pretty sure
june 13th 1987. okay
um
i really don't know if there's any lore
behind cage face
no oh ah oh i don't like that
i can still see outside i don't like oh
okay
oh hey well drinking on the job now we
know what the deal was
hello what the hell
can i go home i solved the mystery it's
a lot of booze here it's problematic
when you're mining
while drunk it's not good all right
anyway i'm gonna go into the where the
deadly gas was
am i seeing something am i seeing
something i can't believe he talked me
into doing this who talked you into
doing what
who what do you mean who did it are you
the person that left the note because if
that's the case then you
are dumb because you decided to run off
not me
or i didn't talk you who's talking to
you am i even a part of this
uranium perfect oh glow sticks this
this isn't the person wait
then the person that left the glow
sticks put the note that said hey
i'm going ahead couldn't wait so excited
i can zoom
all right okay glow stick perfect
okay good good good everything seems to
be in order down here
yep random shifting of rocks is
perfectly normal
in a mine okay
well this is all lovely and i love it
how lovely this is it's lovely as lovely
can be
and uh frankly i don't think that we
need to
investigate any further open and shut
case bunch of drunks went into a
bunch of drunks went into a mine got a
little mine
frivolous and then bob's your uncle they
died
really going deep in this mine hmm
oh blue
someone spilled blood all over the floor
well that happens in mines
everyone knows people are swinging
pickaxes willie and nilly
bloody mine carts you know they gotta
dig out the
the meat i'm guessing these are the meat
mines
or they get the beef maybe it's pork
mine i don't know
it's blood's part of it like that just
happens when you got a meat mine
what else are you gonna do is that girl
i thought that had writing on it or
something
well that would have been creepy good
thing it's not
that hello oh
it's the head oh man this is unfortunate
for me
oh hey well i mean unfortunately for you
you're the dead one
so oh god i should
i'm getting the hell out of here i'm
getting the hell out of here am i gonna
take that or am i gonna
look behind me and there's gonna be a
cage face man
are you okay do you need some ointment
for your pickaxe wounds oh matter
good thing he died at the deepest part
of the mine
the part where everyone was threw down
their pickaxes and was like no more
no more digging not for me
this ain't worth it well that's fine
anyway i gotta get out of here
it's hard to breathe oh well use your
lungs
breathe from the diaphragm suck it up
and keep moving
oh oh oh in front of me is the problem
oh hi
oh what should i do about that oh what
should i do
what should i do okay well you know
that's fine this is totally fine it's
totally fine
all good yeah i thwarted him
she's so stupid this guy with a face of
a cage
stupid cage face dumb ass cage-face
looking loser stupid nerd
full of cage and guy ain't got a brain
in that cage
the bird flew its coop
are you still behind me man i'm not fast
that's the thing about this current
escape is i'm very not
quick current kind of slow actually a
little bit on the slow
side of things oh he's back wait that's
weird
huh he was just behind me and suddenly
he's in front of me
without time to do a loop-de-loop i'm
good at those
i'm real good at the loop-dye loops
i love loop-de-loops they're the best
loops
who doesn't love a good loopy loo all
right see you around
stupid idiot stupid dumb dumb
dumb stupid idiot idi dumbo
dumb dumb idiot dumb not like me big
smart me
big smart breathe big smart gas
running around circles around dumb cage
face man
anyway am i gonna die almost there sure
would be a bad time to collapse in a
heap
at the entrance of this cave sure would
be
unfortunate oh boy booze
glug glug all right let's see if i can
jump no
well that solved that mystery
solved forever cut and dry we all know
what was that oh hey phone
hello hey you're calling right on time
just as i finished watching the tape no
wonder the guy turned out the way he is
now
perhaps i can interview him anyway looks
like i have enough material for my new
story it might even have a name
[Music]
oh there's more than one ending
fascinating
well looks like that's it okay so cage
face interesting
um it need a lot of work i
i will say that it wasn't particularly
scary the ambiance was good
i'll give it that the atmosphere is good
and i did like the setup
of playing the game in the vcr i've seen
that before but it was
i i still like it it was more that you
could have done and also
like the endings aren't exact having
multiple endings is one thing but also
what was the other ending just me losing
i guess was there a third
secret maybe anyway it's fine
so on other news in other news of
characters who are supposed to be
spooky and scary this is oh
day days seven days
this is siren head stranded
[Music]
oh
okay oh
hey hey hey
[Music]
well that was quite an intro
interesting oh i got the oh
fascinating oh fascinating oh
fascinating fascinating wake up my
parents mom
dad find your parents in the field i
don't think i'm supposed to know that
yet but oh
why are you in the field what the frick
hang on i gotta go spooky mode what the
hell
what the heck ain't supposed to be like
this uh this is supposed to be a goof
hey serenade games actually ain't
actually supposed to be spooky
wake up my parents mom dad my mom
i'm brushing me as hard as i can e i'm
eating
real hard mom dad
i'm in as hard as i could
did i encounter a bug already i'm
pressing e as hard
oh i needed the flashlight first i
didn't realize that was
a requirement hey
e okay e works now airplane plus mouth
equals siren really loves paper
airplanes
oh mom dad
oh i'm dead
well you okay i got a paper airplane
all right well let's not jump out of the
gap in my parents house
just yet let's go see what's in the
fridge i'm hungry oh
oh milk glug glug
oh who left the fridge open who put a
paper airplane in the fridge i'm so
confused
okay but that's fine it's all right
don't worry about it
it's all good this door don't eat this
door no he's on this door okay
hello a book
okay i can't jump over that i don't i
don't exactly have mad hops
oh good is that the garage
is there a paper airplane in the garage
i got a funkalicious feeling that i'm
gonna need a lot of paper planes
oh no that's a tree i thought it was a
siren head
oh no did our my parents leave the
radioactive waste barrel out again
oh i told them to put that away
i'm sorry ghost of my mom and dad who's
clearly oh
bessie bessie no
bessie you want paper plane
complain i can't throw a plane at you
the animated a paper plane going in and
hitting off of bessie's nose there
ah yeah that was real good that was
worth the effort to put into making that
happen i'm glad i
asked that how much lyxian favor do i
have in every video
there's got to be a limited amount i
can't just ask willy nilly and that
definitely drained the resources
yeah i'm sorry lexian
seems to maybe be uh
there might be a uh oh
paper plane move paper plane let's do
the paper plane
throw a plane clear a blade
[Music]
i'm dead now all right well that didn't
work
i lose all my paper planes see it it
didn't exactly work
didn't
okay yeah they didn't exactly work uh
and by exactly working it didn't work at
all actually
uh it worked none so i'm not even gonna
bother getting the paper planes i'm just
gonna
go for it oh what's in here this mystery
shed
is this the poop chamber is this the
poop
it's the nothing well i i could poop in
here and go through here
nah some hard corn
who's grumbling who's grumbling
need i remind you
i'm not gonna remind you remind me to
remind you about what i was gonna remind
you of
still don't know how to plane correctly
is this different wait is this different
am i crazy this feels
uh well this is awfully okay well i
don't have a plane
plane would be nice plain jane plane
can't
plane how plane do plane do
let's see and throw a plane across the
screen oh this is going to be awfully
difficult if i can't figure out how to
do the plane
plane plus mouse equals confused
i'm pretty confused i'm
very confused all right i'm gonna try
this again it seemed like the
the maze was actually randomly generated
which i thought was fascinating i
wouldn't have expected that out of this
game
okay i'm how do how would i chuck
i don't know ah no uh uh not this time i
got full sprint baby
yeah you try to catch me
oh i'm being caught oh you're fast
oh you're quick how do we how do you
plane
i'm not crazy am i it says mouse okay
you can crouch
i don't think that's gonna help me
whoever did the audio in this uh
siren head game though doing a great job
i gotta admit the audio
in this one is fantastic really
something special
the controls though need some work
please contact
[Applause]
okay thanks 109.9 okay why do i go
completely blind what if i he'll never
find me
he's gonna find me i i there's no way to
plane how do i plane i'm pressing all of
the plane buttons
pressing every plane button in my
control scheme
what if i just you can't
see me huh
okay you keep going that way you loser
you big dumb idiot
big dumb smelly loser big dumb smelly
loser
[Music]
there's
okay good that's probably my parents
mauled to death real bad that's no good
for anybody especially my parents i wish
i could give you a paper blaine
it would soothe the savage beast resting
inside your heart
you certainly would come to your senses
and realize that wanton murder is
no good for anybody
seems to be working the whole sneaky
tactic usually running screaming
is my go-to strategy and it usually
never fails me
ever but uh wow yeah sneaking huh who
thought oh no no none of that ah oh
wait hang on okay yellow is four
so pink is two so five
is blue uh times two is six so purple's
three
okay easy one of three
of three why does my parents believe in
doing
puzzles so much one of three keys keys
to
why okay so i don't even have a symbol
for paper planes anymore
they don't even exist in this universe
i i don't even i don't even know
i don't even know man i don't even know
how am i gonna well all right
plane no no plane
it's a planeless run
oh hand wait what is that all about what
was uh
what's going on there
okay right
okay yeah pig okay
okay i'm going for it oh this is a maze
even my impeccable sense of direction
might not help me here just go right on
by just go right on through
ride on through don't even worry about
me go right on through
right on third if you could stop blaring
your inception horn for a little bit
my ears might actually be able to hear
again okay thank you
thank you
happy me too
whoa yeah me too me too
us all we all you're not the only one
coincidentally
me also where is anything in this place
i guess i'm just gonna be fallen i'll
have a great view of his ass
as i'm cowering in terror oh yeah yeah
spin that up you know if that was an
actual tornado i would never know i'd be
boned
okay there's something else here oh well
i can't get to it
yeah i want a puzzle i want the addams
family puzzle apparently it's gotta be
this way right
sure we're gonna go with sure we got
something here
okay what is this i'm ready for the
puzzle
oh mega bessie holy crap
there is a blank in the aquarium
fish
okay good well hey i'm on my own no
parents am i right hey
freedom who needs stupid stinky parents
this leads to that farm right so then
down this path
i'm hoping that's another victim because
it gives me more time to survive
so scream all you want oh
oh that is too close this is too close
this is a terrible idea
don't get me i've come so far i don't
know if crouching helps but it makes me
feel better and it's easier to piss my
pants when i'm at a slight crouch
so there's that going for me
if the pig can cut through the corn why
can't i
i don't like how you can sneak up on me
that ain't right
uh wait have i been here already oh
oh wait no this is different wait this
is different what is this please don't
turn around i'm about to solve a puzzle
oh i see okay
wait i can't move okay okay that goes
there that goes there
was there there that sounds oh
come on you son of a [ __ ] i told you
not to turn around
that's dumb this is dumb it's dumb
it's dumb that's dumb why don't the
freaking paper airplanes work huh that's
what i want to know
why don't the paper airplanes do nothing
oh no it is randomly generated
oh i bet it resets every time oh my god
there's a fish in the aquarium
[Music]
yay i did it okay so it's gotta be
something to do with that big ass
whatchama who's it over there
oh no this must be where i leave i see
okay
right okay ah
right okay
oh yeah
like breathing's gonna be scary to me oh
yeah
but what mighty lungs you have grandma
actually in 2020 i guess breathing is
very scary
horrifying this guy just patrols around
the area that he knows i need to get to
that's what he does go away
the other way that way
not closer not oh well they're well oh
okay well i can't see you you can't see
me i can't see you you can't see me i
can't see you you can't see me
i can't see you you can't see me i can't
see you you can't see me i can't see you
you can
see me i can't see i think there must be
just a bug
right that for some reason i was not
able to throw
the things maybe it's because of the e
door situation yeah wow
that's some good info i can't wait to
get that tutorial
oh
wow there's no planes here this
level doesn't have any planes
there's no planes now it just doesn't
even bother giving me planes
there we go plane all right chuck a look
it doesn't work it doesn't work
it doesn't work uh okay
it's just the same answer is two
five three i did it i
did it but why doesn't the plane work
go plane go
woohoo yeehaw my symbol for
plane went away the symbol went away the
symbol
he's coming right for me he's beeline
and straight up my ass
he's coming straight for me no you can't
see me i can't see you
this is baloney bar it did not work it
don't work it don't work it don't work
it don't work i'm not gonna bash my head
up against the wall with it because it
just don't work
you know it don't work that's okay it's
okay sometimes things work sometimes
things don't work
sometimes so that was three scary games
thank you
so much for watching hope you enjoyed
that i did
and they did they always enjoyed
so thank you if you got more scary games
that you want me to play write them in
the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]